so donald trump held another one of
these press briefings yesterday and uh
the the press briefings are increasingly
sort of an outlet for donald trump's
panic over failed interview after failed
interview
on monday night the axios interview that
trump gave to jonathan swann
was such a train wreck that trump
decided yesterday morning
i'm gonna call in to fox and friends
that'll be a nice softball interview
well
we reviewed the fox and friends
interview and again donald trump was a
complete and total disaster
he seems unable to help himself so
yesterday in the afternoon
evening running half an hour late put
him sort of in the evening
category here on the east coast trump
had another one of these white house
press briefings and it was just
unfounded conspiracy after conspiracy
donald trump losing
all connection with reality and i want
to take a look at some of the key
moments now you might remember that on
tuesday
trump had floated the idea that the
explosion in beirut lebanon was an
attack
and he also mentioned that it looked
like a bomb now at the time there was no
evidence of that whatsoever
it was completely irresponsible for
donald trump to float that idea
and since as we learn more about what
went on
there continues to be a complete lack of
evidence that that is what happened
donald trump was asked about it
yesterday and multiple
times doubled down floating even more
conspiratorial ideas
about explosive devices all with zero
evidence also one other thing here that
i want you to pay special attention to
you're going to notice that trump starts
referring to lebanon
as that country he never says the word
lebanon during this entire press
briefing
it looks to me that donald trump doesn't
know that beirut
is in lebanon and so he avoids having to
make that clear by referring to lebanon
as that country pay special attention to
that
the primary focus of this clip is
trump's baseless conspiracies
so there's been some question about your
comments yesterday
saying that it was an attack and that
you heard from military officials
that there was uh you know an explosion
that looked like something sort of
i can tell you whatever happened it's
terrible but they don't really know what
it is nobody knows yet
at this moment they're looking it could
i mean how can you say accident somebody
was
you know left some terrible
explosive type devices and things around
perhaps
perhaps
it was that perhaps it was an attack i
don't think anybody can say right now
we're looking into it very strongly
right now it's uh
i mean you have some people think it was
an attack and you have some people that
think it wasn't
in any event it was a terrible event and
a lot of people were killed and a
tremendous number of people were badly
wounded injured and we're standing with
with that country you know we have a
very good relationship with that country
but it's a country under
it's a lot of turmoil a lot of problems
but we stand with them
none of what donald trump said there is
based in any fact
he says maybe someone left explosive
devices
there's no evidence of that he's just
making that up
some people think it was an attack there
could have been
explosive devices there's no connection
to reality whatsoever now you expect
this stuff
from you know the enclaves of the
internet that we've all come to
sadly be familiar with over the last
three and a half years
but this is the president of the united
states just randomly
and wildly floating conspiracies that
occur to him
then another one here donald trump uh
posits
without any evidence that there was some
kind of conspiracy
in new york congressional primaries
all to make him look bad this is just
wild and unhinged
new york they had the carolyn maloney
situation
and i criticized it badly over the last
two years in
two days i mean i gave it some very very
strong criticism
and all of a sudden like a miracle they
just approved the winner well what
happened did the
person that was second concede the race
even though it was
very close and all mixed up they have a
terrible situation in new york with the
ballots you know that
and as soon as i said well i think you
should have a new election because the
election obviously they're not going to
know what to do i think you should have
a new election
they all of a sudden announced a winner
i assume it was her but they announced
the winner
well i don't agree with it did somebody
speak to the person on the other
side the opponent did they do something
for the opponent on the other side
take a look at patterson new jersey take
a look at many things it's all over
newspapers
what's going on with the mail-in ballots
they've they send out millions of
ballots millions of ballots they're
totally unprepared to do it
and then they come back in the millions
uh it's going to be a disaster
completely baseless allegations and
remember
donald trump keeps talking about vote by
mail fraud
as a reason not to vote by mail in
november
and he points to this new york race
this situation in new york is related to
postmarks and mishandling by the city
there has been no voter fraud alleged
in this race at all never mind confirmed
none of that race has anything to do
with fraud
and yet donald trump is fully in with
these baseless
conspiracies now then at the end of the
press briefing
again the topic of beirut was brought up
and trump sort of stumbles through the
answer and abruptly ends the press
briefing again
failing to ever say the word lebanon it
seems to me
trump doesn't know that beirut is in
lebanon
uh and again saying it could have been a
bomb that was set off
despite there being no evidence posited
so far
said today that based on what
he had heard the incident in beirut
he felt was an accident now he's
disagreed with you on other things
before do you have any comment
about his remark whatever he uh if he if
that's what he heard i think that i've
heard it both ways too
i've heard accent i've heard you know
explosives and
obviously it must have been some form of
explosives but whether it was a bomb
intentionally set off it ended up being
a bomb
but no i've heard it both ways it could
have been an accident and it could have
also been something that was very
offensive
and uh i wouldn't be very happy with
to follow up on that mr president even
if you just have suspicion that the
beirut explosion
is a bomb do you have any plans of
pertaining to you as assets in the
region for example i mean how are you
looking into this
we're working very closely with the
government and we're working very
closely with many different agencies
including the military
and we'll be able to figure it out we
already probably have figured it out
thank you very much everybody
abruptly walking off of course after
floating multiple
multiple unfounded conspiracy theories
now just a bonus clip here
not a conspiracy per se but just the
wild claim donald trump again
talks about you know coronavirus is just
going to go away
sir uh you said an interview this
morning on the corona virus this thing's
going away
it'll go away like things go away
despite ongoing cases
isn't actually true it's going away no
it'll go away like things go away
absolutely it's no question in my mind
it will go away please go ahead
hopefully sooner rather than later now
what's pernicious about this is that to
the non-thinking individual
eventually trump's going to be right and
he's going to get some credit for that
and what i mean by that is
i guess it's conceivable that the the
coronavirus goes away as a pandemic but
it becomes sort of seasonal like the flu
but in a certain sense eventually trump
will be right that the pandemic is going
to end now
trump has been saying this for months
when we had 15 cases
the president said they would soon be
zero we're now at 5 million
he's been saying it's going to go away
for five months at a certain point
he will be right and there are people in
our country
so uneducated or so blinded by
partisanship that they're going to
praise trump for it they will say look
trump said it was going to go away and
it went away
it is weaponized ignorance and
aggressive delusion and it's dangerous
and i do you guys think these briefings
are helping trump with some people like
do these briefings help
trump with his base or are they doing
more harm than good you'll remember they
were stopped for a period of time and
then restarted as an idea for
helping donald trump recover in the
polls he actually
has seen slightly better polling since
he has restarted these although to make
a causal relationship
uh we'd have to have a little more
information what do you think helping
hurting trump no
impact helping with his base but hurting
with everybody else
curious what you think if you are
anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video